Я не дуже люблю автівки. І водіння теж.
І все ж вийшло так, що я переїхала саме на батьківщину BMW, Porsche, Mercedes-Benz і - Міхаеля Шумахера!
Ну, і звісно легендарних автобанів!
Ви готові?
Що ж, поїхали!
Ласкаво прошу на німецький автобан, де швидкість не знає меж.
Близько 70% автомагістралей у ФРН не мають обмежень швидкості.
Але слід враховувати численні затори і постійні ремонтні роботи.
Німеччина - одна із небагатьох країн, де немає загального обмеження швидкості.
Але дискусії про це - доволі гаряча тема в Німеччині, особливо на тлі таких аргументів, як безпека, довкілля і особиста свобода.
У будь-якому випадку переважна більшість німців все одно їздять не так швидко.
Середня швидкість на трасах без обмежень - 122 кілометри на годину.
Хочете покататися німецькими автобанами?
Тоді ви мусите дотримуватися кількох золотих правил.
По-перше, триматися правої смуги.
Це означає, що середню і ліву смуги можна використовувати лише для обгону,
Не можна обганяти у правій смузі - хіба що ви стоїте в заторі.
До речі, у заторах німецькі водії зазвичай формують так звану "смугу порятунку" -
дорогу для рятувальних служб, якщо їм раптом необхідно буде проїхати.
Продовжуючи тему дорожніх правил: німцям дозволяється водити з 17 років у супроводі дорослого і з 18-ти самостійно.
Штрафні бали за перевищення швидкості чи інші порушення ПДР називають "пункти у Фленсбурзі" -
це місто, де розташоване управління дорожнього руху.
Того, хто назбирає забагато штрафних балів, особливо за водіння напідпитку чи під дією наркотиків, позбавляють водійських прав.
Відновлення прав можливе лише після тривалої і дорогої медико-психологічної експертизи,
яку німці в народі називають "тест на ідіота".
Єдине місце, де я на відпочинку за кордоном завжди зустрічаю німців, - це автомийка.
А в Німеччині багатьох німців можна побачити у довжелезних чергах по суботах,
де ті стоять, аби помити свої кохані автівки.
У 2020 році 77% німецьких домогосподарств мали бодай одну машину.
В одному опитуванні 55% респондентів заявили, що відчувають радість уже від того, що просто бачать свою машину.
Але є інше дослідження, яке засвідчує, що молоде покоління значно менш емоційно прив'язане до своїх автівок.
Що для вас значить ваша машина?
Все! Це ж мій улюбленець!
Це свого роду свобода!
Особисто? Небагато!
Свобода з мобільністю!
Я пропрацював в автопромі понад 40 років,але цікавлюся автомобільним дизайном, не більше того.
Німеччина надто залежна від автомобілів?
Так, надто багато машин.
Дивишся навколо - всюди автівки.
Слід сідати за кермо лише тоді, коли немає іншої альтернативи.
Я живу в селі, тому я мушу їздити.
Громадський транспорт треба покращити, щоб люди могли відмовитися від автівок.
А ще - розвивати сервіси з каршерінгу.
Але це й вагомий економічний фактор. Хочеться, щоб країні економічно добре йшлося. Автопром важливий для Німеччини.
Гаразд, повернімося до витоків!
Німець Карл Бенц вважається винахідником сучасного автомобіля.
Його дружина Берта Бенц нібито першою здійснила поїздку на машині,
коли відвезла своїх двох синів із Маннгейма до Пфорцгейма в 1888 році.
Майбутній канцлер Німеччини, а тодішній мер Кельна Конрад Аденауер
був відповідальний за перший відрізок автобану в Німеччині - між Кельном і Бонном.
Однак в 1930-х роках нацисти спробували присвоїти собі появу німецьких автобанів, які вони називали "Рейхсавтобан".
Гітлер також ініціював створення компактного автомобіля для широких мас.
Так виник Volkswagen, що буквально означає "народний автомобіль".
З початком Другої світової війни виробництво автівок перевели з цивільних на військові потреби.
Тож, лише наприкінці 1945-го "Фольксваґен", який тоді був під контролем Великобританії,
почав масове виробництво всесвітньо відомого "Жука".
"Фольксваґен жук" згодом позбувся свого нацистського минулого
і став символом економічного відродження Західної Німеччини.
А вже в 1955-му Фольксваґен випустив свого мільйонного "жука".
Згодом ця та інші моделі стали символом свободи, подорожей і статусу.
У той час, як західні німці мали "жука", східні отримали "Трабант" або "Трабі".
Культова автівка випускалася в Цвікау в Саксонії.
Зовнішній корпус робили з твердого пластику.
Черга на придбання "трабі" тривала 12-15 років.
Фото "трабантів", які заїжджають в Західну Німеччину, - один з найбільш знакових символів возз'єднання країни.
А що нині? Автомобільна промисловість досі глибоко вкорінена в німецькій економіці.
Це найбільша галузь економіки країни, в якій задіяно сотні тисяч працівників,
і вона непрямо підтримує багато інших галузей.
Приміром, третина усіх дослідників у Німеччині працює в автопромі.
Німецькі автомобілі давно зарекомендували себе як інноваційні.
Слоган "Ауді" 1970-го року "Прогрес через технології" закріпився в міжнародному сприйнятті Німеччини.
Щоправда, були й серйозні удари по автогалузі у ФРН -
не в останню чергу через маніпуляції з дизельними викидами
і небажання перевести галузь на більш зелені технології.
Нині "Фольксваґен" займає друге місце у світі за виробництвом електрокарів.
А лідер електромобільності "Тесла" планує відкрити гігантську фабрику неподалік Берліна.
Коли це буде дешевше для покупців, вони купуватимуть електромобілі.
Але спершу слід змінити інфраструктуру і поліпшити можливості для зарядки.
Думаю, це проблематично і не зовсім екологічно.
Я проти цього. Електрокари ще не до кінця випробувані, і ми не знаємо, як на них їхати.
Вони можуть проїхати 200 кілометрів - яка з цього користь?
Питання радше в тому, як зміниться мобільність.
Тобто чи ми всі далі матимемо власні автомобілі чи в нас буде інший спосіб пересування.
Дякую всім, хто просив висвітлити цю тему.
Тішуся, що мені вдалося зробити цілу серію без того, щоб самій сісти за кермо.
Розкажіть у коментарях про свої пригоди на німецьких автобанах
і про те, що ви думаєте про німецьку любов до авто.